hi hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for
january 13 2021 and
according to my records joe biden will
be inaugurated as president
of the united states of america in one
week from today
right now he's doing everything from the
office of the president-elect
that is not a real thing but i guess
maybe they have an office somewhere but
it was never a thing before any of this
but here we are
anyway today's show uh is going to be an
interesting one because i feel like when
we went through the topics last night
and then into this morning
virtually everything that we're going to
cover today we're going to do four
stories we got a whole bunch of clips a
little bit more than usual
virtually everything that we're going to
talk about today is sort of like
wheelhouse exactly everything i've kind
of been warning against
that i've been fighting against that i
wrote a book against that i wish had not
happened but i sort of saw coming
that i think you guys are concerned
about and will also
sort of lead to what i think we're going
to just get much
much more of in the in the coming years
uh unfortunately how about that
uh guys just want to remind you real
quick before we start though that in
response
to the social media bannings and the
censorship and everything else
uh that my friends at blaze media are
offering a 30
discount on annual subscriptions just
for a limited time i think they're doing
this just for another day or two
so you can go to head you can head over
to blazetv.com
and sign up today and of course you can
get all of my
stuff on blaze tv and i just love the
blaze team i love glenn and tyler
and everything they're doing over there
i'm going to be doing a couple reuben
reports
live excuse me i'm going to be doing a
couple of reuben reports live
from dallas at the end of the month i
believe on the
28th and 29th i will be live in dallas
and i'm doing a whole bunch of shows and
have a couple meetings
i've said too much okay let's talk about
the state of the world
joe biden from the office of the
president-elect
they've decided that their theme
for inauguration and i suppose for the
coming months
will be unity so i've got a quote here
from fox news
the theme of president-elect joe biden's
inauguration
is america united despite deep divisions
in the country
and will be focused on a new national
journey that the biden team says will
restore the soul of america
and bring the country together okay so
let's talk a little bit about the word
unity right because the word unity
sounds good we want unity
we want people to like each other we
want to agree
on what america is and what it could be
and all of those good things that's all
very nice
except does it really sound like they
want unity are the messages you're
getting
out of the democratic party right now or
actually really from anyone at this
point
are you really getting messages of unity
or are you getting messages of
conformity because i'm getting a lot of
messages of conformity we're going to
get to a little bit
more on that in just a second i'm
getting a lot of messages of
oh now we've got to destroy obviously
donald trump
but any of his supporters and they've
gone from being racists
to terrorists and everything else i'm
not getting a lot of unity like
unity to me i'll tell you what unity is
unity to dave rubin
would be that oh we respect that america
has been here for around 250 years
we respect that people from all over the
world have come here to make a better
life
for themselves and for their families
and that they've done it
we respect that these people have all
sorts
of different beliefs different customs
different traditions different religions
and we actually revel in that we
actually
are happy that we have all of these
differences and that the unity
is the respect that all of those
differences
are tolerable in a free society that
would be unity to me
now the unity though that i sense that
the democrats are offering that mr
president-elect
is offering is that we will have unity
in that we're going to have a very
specific
set of things that you're allowed to
believe and if you believe those things
we will be unified
if you do not believe those things or if
you do not purport to believe those
things publicly
and believe a whole bunch of different
stuff privately which i sense a lot of
people are going to start doing
then we can't have unity then you are a
bad guy and we're going to have to treat
you as such
the reason i want to do this story first
is going to set up everything else i'm
going to talk about but i think this is
sort of
important because it's relative to the
what i would say is going to be a
continuing and an expansion of just
orwellian language that we're constantly
going to be told we're going to be told
we have to heal
we're going to be told that we need
unity and all of those things and it all
sounds right and i'm pretty sure if
you've been watching me for a long time
if you've read my book if you've seen
any videos that i've done anywhere
any of the things that i've done on
prageru about
tolerance or why i left the left or any
of those things that
i am for having a wide
variety of opinions of in society i am
for
having people living in the same country
and the same state in the same city that
i live in
that i vehemently disagree with i am
fine having neighbors that i might
completely disagree with about politics
but if unity to you means that
you got to believe what i believe thus
we are unified
then we have a real problem and that
really is kind of what they mean and if
you don't believe me if you don't
believe me well watch this segway that
i'm about to make
as a television internet professional to
segment two because the media
is really really right now just going
bananas
all in on not only the destruction of
trump and that
is what it is and maybe at some level he
made his bet
on some of it uh but really the
destruction of anyone who had anything
to do with trump and anyone who
supported
trump and before i show these clips you
guys know i went to a couple of trump
rallies
in l.a and i got to tell you i only saw
good decent people there that is not to
defend
the people who clearly were violent that
were trump supporters at the
at the capitol a couple days ago but the
vast majority of these people
i mean vast vast vast majority of these
people
are good decent hard-working patriotic
americans who love this country and just
want it to be better
and every time they put their voice out
there they're called all of the worst
things but don't take my word for it
here's juliet kayam a cnn analyst
on cnn exactly so i so we're not there
yet and i think what we have to remember
is
trump is the um spiritual but i will
also say
operational leader of this domestic
terrorism effort he tells them where to
go
he tells them what to do he tells them
why they're angry
and so we need to start at the top like
any counterterrorism effort which is
total isolation of the president of the
united states
impeachment yes 25th amendment yes
deplatforming yes
all of the above no money no access to
campaign funds
a complete isolation because as the
leader of a terrorist organization
is viewed as a loser as a not winner it
is harder for him to recruit
look he's going to have his radical
elements we will arrest them we will
isolate them
but what we have to make sure is that
donald trump does not have a second act
i know i sound
incredibly harsh right now calling the
president uh this
but we are in the tactical response
right now enough with the let's unity
and stuff this is a
tactical effort right now to make sure
that we protect american citizens and of
course the next president of the united
states
everything that juliette just said right
there is completely bananas okay because
think about it if trump is the head of a
terrorist organization right and must be
decapitated as the head of the terrorist
organization
then that means in effect she's saying
that the 74 million people who supported
him
are terrorists i know you guys are not
terrorists i am not a terrorist
i am against political violence now
ironically there's been all sorts
of political violence coming from the
left and it's been cheered on
by the democratic leaders and it's been
cheered on by the mainstream media we'll
get to that
in just a little bit but that type of
over-the-top rhetoric i do
actually admire her at one moment when
she says well i don't care about the
unity thing she's actually
saying something that's a little more
honest there biden's faking the unity
thing knowing what the media will do
for him so biden can say i'm for unity
while the media will try to destroy all
these people and then the systems that
he puts in place as the president
will try to destroy all these people
she's actually being a little more
honest like ah forget about unity this
guy's a terrorist
and and we've got to take him out and
everything else and and impeachment's
not enough and 25th amendment's not
enough i mean this is
this is truly truly over-the-top
dangerous rhetoric uh but you're not
going to believe this guys it's not just
cnn here's eugene robinson on
msnbc we have um there are millions of
americans
almost all white almost all republicans
who somehow need to be deprogrammed
there
it's as if they don't they they are
members of a cult
the trumpist cult uh and and who have to
be deprogrammed do you have any idea how
we
how we start that process much less
depleted
yeah i i don't know i'm a journalist i
certainly um
don't know how we can stop people i know
we can look to history though
uh what ultimately uh breaks that power
structure
in the south is enforcement right there
has to be consequences
uh and then once you get those
consequences i think then people have to
take
a second look at their actions and they
have to be much more
afraid to do the types of kind of
violence that we saw
this week uh last week the violence that
we've seen building you know with what
happened in michigan the violence that's
being threatening now
um what has long been the case in this
country is that we have wanted to
quickly move on to reconciliation
when it comes to this sort of divide
we've always been afraid that if you
actually punish
those kind of white nationalist element
in our society will only make things
worse but
in fact what history shows is not
reacting
not forcing accountability only
emboldens
those people in those movements so i
think there has to be some real
accountability
there has to be some enforcement of the
laws and then
after that i think is when you can start
trying to build reconciliation
but i think what what is clearly the
case is not doing anything
um is only emboldening uh this to expand
unity guys can you feel the unity i mean
eugene wants us deprogrammed
i mean how about camps re-education
camps maybe gulags that would be nice
for all of these people and when he says
this thing about mostly white there are
no he says there are millions of
americans almost all
white well first off joe biden's white
support actually went up not donald
trump's that was the problem because
donald trump actually doubled black male
support black female support also went
up his lgbt support went up we know he
did very well
with hispanics and i don't even care
about any of that stuff and i think the
point is that trump supporters don't
even care about that stuff
but i think we're going to have to start
separating trump's supporters and
whatever this movement
this sort of pro-america movement is
from trump himself because
because it's just these people are
making it impossible to have an honest
conversation about anything
but does uh what you just saw there on
msnbc
does that seem like we're going to come
around to unity does that seem like
we're going to come around
to anything about healing or tolerant
tolerance or decency
i don't really think so but let's even
go further because
forbes magazine had an article by a man
named randall lane and here's what he
had to
say about you evil white supremacists he
said trump's liars don't merit that same
golden parachute let it be known to the
business world
hire any of trump's fellow fabulists
above and
forbes will assume that everything your
company or firm talks about is a lie
we're going to scrutinize double check
investigate with the same skepticism
we'd approach
a trump tweet want to ensure the world's
biggest
business media brand approaches you as a
potential funnel of disinformation
then hire away watch out trump people if
you
worked for trump if you supported trump
if you went to a rally
not only are we going to say all the
horrible things about you that we've
been saying all along but we're also
going to make sure you can't get a
job you can't work and you're going to
be under
extra scrutiny and who knows you can't
get on a plane and we might just lock in
your house and again the camps we're
getting the camps ready
i know this all sounds sort of nuts and
yet we're here do i
do i seem like i'm saying anything crazy
other than telling you what exactly is
happening right now
it's it's just unfortunate and nutty and
as i tweeted out yesterday and it went
pretty viral
what seems particularly odd to me at
this point is after what happened at the
capitol
trump had about eight nine days left
right it's it's a week from today
um after what happened at the capitol
you know as as the the
sort of republicans support the and i
don't even mean like the pure
trumpist support but like the
establishment republican mcconnell those
guys support
as that sort of bottomed out it was like
trump was
gonna go away it just seems like sort of
obvious
like that something he was just gonna go
away he went to
the wall in uh in texas yesterday showed
off there's 450 miles of wall he took a
picture there
but he was kind of going away they've
they've completely crippled his met
his ability to get messaging out there
because they banned him for from
everything it does seem like we might
have a
structure more powerful than the
government that's a bit of a problem but
i don't want to
belabor the point um but he was about to
go away then they run in with the
impeachment thing
25th amendment putting people on no
phylus and the rest of it and it's like
it sort of feels like a slow coo and we
don't even know where it's coming from i
mentioned yesterday it feels like we're
all
being just dumped with the pink slime
from ghostbusters 2 that makes everybody
hate everybody
and they're doing they're pouring it on
everybody while they're telling us
that we should be healing and love
everybody and everything else it's it's
very bizarre
let's move over to covid we haven't
talked about covet in a couple days
because pandemics
they get paused when other things are
happening you know what i mean when
worldwide pandemics and lockdowns and
shutdowns are happening
you can pause them uh for a couple days
when other things are happening or
if a guy that you likes get voted in
you're allowed to be out there
rallying and and you know passing around
bottles of champagne like they did in
brooklyn and things like that
well andrew cuomo who's been probably
the worst governor in all of the united
states and i say that probably because i
am here in california
and i do have gavin newsom and i have
signed the recall and you know what i
think about
gavin newsom and you know what he did at
french laundry and fifteen thousand
dollars worth of wine without masks and
social distancing and everything else
he's pretty horrible uh but he didn't
directly kill people and andrew cuomo
did by sending a lot of old people back
into the old age homes we all know about
that andrew cuomo then
wrote a book about leadership in the
midst of all of this
um and i think got an emmy or something
like the whole thing is just
absolutely bananas but here's a tweet
from andrew cuomo who has kept new york
virtually closed who has destroyed the
economy and destroyed restaurants and
small businesses
and acts more like a mafia leader than a
governor he tweeted
we simply cannot stay closed until the
vaccine
hits critical mass the cost is too high
we will have nothing left to open we
must reopen the economy
but we must do it smartly and safely
oh andrew are you saying lockdowns don't
work
are you saying there's no evidence that
what you did in new york
which has destroyed the economy and
ruined lives and caused depression
and all sorts of other stuff are you
saying that that might be worse than
what
ron desantis did in florida which was
keep things open and allow people to be
outside
and allow people to eat and wear masks
and do all of that stuff and not destroy
absolutely everything in the name of
accumulating power are you saying you
might have got some of that stuff
wrong i don't think you're quite saying
that but you are saying it you know
these are not good people but what they
are what they are priming the pump for
is that once biden is inaugurated
suddenly they're going to open
everything up
it will look as if biden saved the world
and the democrats are all the good guys
because the economy was destroyed under
trump
but suddenly magically we've decided oh
no we do have to open things up and i
have no doubt
that over the next couple days you'll
see messaging from gavin newsom like
this too well
we've decided the lockdowns they did
what they could do
but now we must open up los angeles
which should have been open this entire
time at the
very least outdoor uh dining because it
is freaking as
as it always is today it's about 75
degrees and beautiful and i can't sit
outside
and have a uh avocado salad
as a good member of the los angeles
community i just can't do it
anyway these people are ridiculous
hypocrites and finally segment four
uh you're not going to believe this guys
but a lot of the democrats
and hypocrisy no knows bound knows no
bounds there are
uh lefty hypocrites they're righty
hypocrites we're all hypocrites at some
level
but hypocrisy seems to be going off the
charts right now
i'm going to show you a couple videos of
some democrat leaders sort of calling
for violence and you know promoting uh
terrorist
activity by their own words but first i
want to show you this video from
yesterday
this is new senate majority leader chuck
schumer talking about the no-fly list
that all
of the protesters that were at the
capitol the other day
should be on and note the visual aid
that he is using while he talks about
the no-fly list
let's take a look any of those who are
inside the capital
should not be able to fly and should be
placed on the no-fly list we are calling
on the authorities
tsa department of homeland security to
put them on the no-fly list immediately
yes thank you chuck if you weren't
holding a piece of
laminated paper with an airplane crossed
out i would have had no idea what a
no-fly list meant
we are literally guys literally in
idiocracy too
it's a reality show and it's happening
right now you remember the scene in
idiocracy right at the beginning when he
goes to the hospital
and they ask him his name he ends up
saying not sure and that's why they call
him not sure throughout the movie but he
has to put this thing in his mouth or
the other thing in his butt he gets it
confused and they're showing him
all the visual aids airplane crossed out
no fly list that's what we're in right
now we're in it these people
are these these are not my leaders i
don't know whose leaders these are i
don't know who thinks that these are
serious people
who should have any power over any of us
uh also the idea of the no-fly list you
know this is
kind of funny because lefties for a long
time were upset about the no-fly list
because they felt that it was going to
disproportionately impact either people
of color or muslim people
because it had something to do with
terror the now of course they're not
going to say anything about it because
they're going to be thrilled that it's
it's trump supporters that are put on
there now of course if you violently did
anything at the capitol you should be
prosecuted without question there's just
no doubt about that
the idea generally though of a no-fly
list seems like a very strange thing to
me it's like all right
we think you're kind of a bad guy and in
this case we have no evidence that you
would do anything on a plane
so we're just not going to let you fly
you know what i mean we're just not
going to let you go to cabo
okay no cabo for you you can drive
to arizona if you'd like or you could
drive all the way across country but
we're not going to let you fly from
denver to austin
that'll that'll stop it it doesn't even
really make sense
but that even wasn't even the point of
why i showed you that uh
i've got a plane here there's a light
crossed through it
okay let's uh look at some democrats
promoting violence though
uh here's a little compilation of such
luminaries as cory booker maxine waters
hillary clinton
all promoting protests and kind of wink
winking
to violence let's roll before i end
that's my call to action here
please don't just come here today and
then go home go to the hill today
get up and please get up in the face of
some congress people
already you have members of your cabinet
that are being booed out of restaurants
[Music]
they have protesters taking up at their
house
no sleep and guess what we're gonna win
this battle
because while you try and quote the
bible jeff sessions and others
you really don't know the bible god is
on our side
on the side of the children on the side
of what's right
on the side of what's honorable on the
side of
understanding that if we can't protect
the children
we can't protect anybody and so
let's save the course let's make sure we
show up
wherever we have to show up and if you
see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not
welcome
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to
destroy what you stand for what you care
about
that's why i believe if we are fortunate
enough
to win back the house and or the senate
that's when civility can start again
but until then the only thing that the
republicans seem to
recognize and respect is strength
do you feel the civility do you feel the
healing
do you feel the unity people a couple
quotes get
up in the face cory booker take up at
their house
maxine waters no peace no sleep maxine
waters
hillary clinton you cannot be civil
although she does qualify by saying once
we have power
then you can be civil i think today was
the best
direct message i've done in the few
months we've been doing it i feel clear
people
i know it's craziness right now but i
feel freaking clear i'm willing
to keep going with you uh i want a civil
society
i want a place that is open to all sorts
of people who i agree with and disagree
with
i love america i love this country i
love our founding documents i'm going to
keep fighting for it i hope you will too
if you want to join me over on locals
it's locals.reubenreport.com and you can
watch my interview
with former overstock ceo and and tech
guru
patrick byrne which we put up this
morning on youtube thank you
and good luck